Now before we wrap this project up, I want to
take a minute to connect some of the ideas that
we have seen in this lesson thus far. We started
out by creating squares and we wrote a piece of
code that said brad is equal to turtle.Turtle. What we
were really doing behind the scenes there is creating an
object or an instance of the class turtle. What we
could then do with that instance is things like brad.forward.
We then wanted to do things like read contents
from a file on our computer, so we wrote a
piece of code that said quotes equal to open a
file location. What we were really doing behind the scenes
there, is create an object of the type file. We
could then do things with that object like quotes.read. And
when we wanted to access a website on the internet,
we wrote a piece of code that said connection is
equal to urllib.urlopen. Now this piece of
code also returned a file-like object or instance
and we could then do things with
that instance, like connection.read. In all three of
these examples, we created instances or objects
and then we used those objects. Now some
of you may say that in the profanity editor example, all we used were functions.
Functions like open and urlopen and that there was no class like we saw in the
previous example with turtle. Well even though on surface
it looks like we did not use any classes
in the profanity editor example, if you look at
how functions like open and urlopen are actually implemented
in Python, we will find that some classes init
like function is being called to return these objects.
Okay, let's look at one more example of how to
use classes. Things will get a lot clearer after that.